hey what up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome back to my OpenGL series so
today we're gonna have a nice chill
episode in which we just talk about how
we're going to abstract some of the code
that we've actually written in the past
episodes out into some classes so that
we can use it more easily as we start to
get into more complicated OpenGL stuff
which is obviously where this series is
headed so I did mention a few times
throughout creating this series that I
really don't want to make this a game
engine series I don't want to make it
like hey we're gonna build some kind of
OpenGL engine or like a rendering engine
or anything like that I don't really
want to spend too much time moving code
around and setting stuff up and making
it absolutely bulletproof and absolutely
perfect because that's not the point of
this series this series is just me
showing you how to use OpenGL however in
the real world in order to actually use
OpenGL you do need to perform some kind
of abstraction of some sort because
you're otherwise you're just gonna end
up having a pile just a messy pile of
code that doesn't make much sense to you
it's gonna be extremely verbose and
you're just gonna it's it's gonna be
difficult to debug there's all sorts of
issues and it's gonna be extremely
difficult for me to show you for example
how to implement shadow mapping if I'm
all doing it in one file with just raw
organ gel kind of card because it's just
it's not gonna make much sense so what
I'm going to do over the next few
episodes is start moving code out into
classes and showing you how we can kind
of I guess move common code around so
that we can reuse it a lot of times
maybe parameterize it as well and all
that stuff it's also a really good
opportunity to show me a little bit or
for me to show you guys a little bit
about how like how OpenGL can be
abstracted and how like it typically
would be abstracted in a game engine
even though we're not going to go as
deep into this as if I was actually
writing again mentioned potentially with
multiple rendering at the eyes it's
gonna be fairly like brief and
high-level here but still it's a really
good chance for me to just show you guys
how you would typically go about
abstracting um gel anyway so out of what
we've done so far there are a few things
that we need to actually move around
there's the vertex buffer setup right
the index buffer setup
to raise as well and whether or not we
even want to use them I've said in the
previous episode I think which was about
vertex arrays that we will be using them
so we need to set up some kind of
abstraction for that and then there's
the whole shader situation that's
probably it like if you really think
about what we've done so far we haven't
done textures yet or anything like that
or like you know frame buffers the right
thing or anything like that
I said obviously it's not like we have a
complete like every feature OpenGL
implemented in this main file but it is
getting a bit lengthy I think it's like
about 200 lines of code and it's getting
a little bit hard to tell what's
actually going on and it's a little bit
hard to read but in terms of what I just
listed out their bellies buffer index
buffer vertex around shader that's
pretty much all we have right now that
we can abstract however there is one
thing that needs to tie everything
together and that is traditionally known
as a renderer so we do need to create a
renderer at some point as well and the
idea where the renderer is fairly simple
you basically give it like a command and
it will render that thing for you so in
other words I want to be able to say hey
renderer
can you please draw me this and then the
draw kind of function will potentially
take in everything it needs to draw
something which you traditionally would
be like a vertex buffer an index buffer
potentially any kind of textures any
render states such as like you want
blending on should we be writing to the
depth buffer that kind of stuff and then
obviously what does a better go find a
spot for like a materials like a shadow
maybe texture stuff like that and then
all the render stacks right so that that
kind of concept of a renderer needs to
also exist and that's gonna be extremely
important for us to implement so what
we're gonna do is today just focus on
vertex buffers in in and index buffers
which should be very easy especially
because we've decided to use vertex
arrays so we don't have to worry about
the layout of an actual vertex buffer
when we write that vertex buffer class
we only care about the actual data which
is just a bunch of bytes
really easy to really easy to deal with
at this point and then the index buffer
is basically the exact same thing
like literally index of a vertical
buffer basically the same thing as far
as the abstraction and
thing like that and then in the next
episode we'll probably deal with vertex
arrays and then after that probably
shaders and then after that maybe the
renderer and then once we have all that
kind of collection of classes set up
we'll be able to actually use them to do
things in a relatively easy way that
should look very simple in this
application like file class thing that
we have going on right now so that's the
plan let's dive in let's start cracking
this code okay so first of all if I just
hit f5 so I can show you guys where
we're at of course is where we left off
in the other episode we basically just
created a vertex array and how to do
this little animation of our rectangle
color here
the main things that I'm going to be
focusing on today is this vertex buffer
which is right over here we'll just
called a buffer and that's to take
that's just taking in these float
positions and that's pretty much it and
then of course the index buffer which is
this thing here now this kind of stuff
this vertex attribute stuff which is at
the actual layout of a vertex buffer
that's going to be dealt with in the
vertex array class and all that and
virtus array class will probably end up
taking vertex buffer objects into it as
well because we typically tie their Tex
buffer we typically tie vertex buffers
with actual vertex of rays in their
layouts and all that kind stuff and then
after that of course will go with
shaders shadows are gonna be a little
bit more complicated because we need to
actually deal with the uniforms and all
that so that should be a fun episode but
anyway today nice and simple vertex
buffer end index buffer how do we do
that stuff so first of all if we scroll
up to the very top you'll see we have
some stuff that's fairly common right
like this error checking is stuff that's
kind of common to OpenGL right now so
what I'm going to do is on the source
over here going to right-click add new
item I'm going to just add a header file
and I'm just gonna call it renderer
again I don't really want to set this up
like a game engine or anything so I'm
not going to go and not to try to create
too many classes so I'll keep it nice
and simple hours put into the renderer
class which will eventually contain our
renderer as well so I'm making a CPP
file as well because we need that so we
have a renderer CDP and a renderer dot H
okay into the renderer H I'm actually
going to put in this a cert which might
not seem very intuitive because
assertions are typically used throughout
our entire program not just the renderer
but it's okay
in fact I'm just gonna copy and paste
all of this kind of stuff cut it and
then put it into render
H which is pinned accidentally whoops
okay cool so now this is what we have
I'm going to include some stuff now we
are obviously tying this with the shell
so it's okay to just include glue over
here in our render a header file and
then what else we need I re and
potentially we don't really need that
stuff here I'm not going to include
iostream all we need is really just flu
okay cool so now this stuff what do we
do with this stuff well the first thing
I'm going to do is get rid of static and
then just make it a an actual
declaration rather than definition
because we're going to move that
definition into the actual CPP file so
I'll get rid of static for GL for GL log
call as well add a semicolon in fact
let's just copy both of this we're going
to put it into the CPP file in there
I'll include round rotation paste in
this stuff then I'm back over here I'm
going to just get rid of the bodies of
these two functions like that and there
we go
okay looks pretty simple and then in
render recipie P we've all that stuff
let's get rid of these semicolons now
here we will actually need to include C
out so let's say include iostream and
that looks pretty good to me okay so
we've removed it we've moved out the
kind of common stuff and we can just
include renderer in all of our classes
if we really need to to get access to
this kind of jail call macro and
everything that it does as well as
assert cool okay so back an application
let's take a look at what we actually
need to move out here so straight away
you can see GL call of course is giving
us an error because we now need to
include renderer because we need the
macro and then we'll scroll down and
take a look at this buffer stuff so this
is the actual code that we need and that
really is like all of it I mean this
bind buffer will need to kind of be
reused in some kind of bind method
because we will have to rebind kind of
different buffers as we go along but the
actual creation is just gem buffers and
then setting the data that's it really
easy really simple so under source I'm
gonna click right click add new item
gonna be a header file am I going to
pull this vertex buffer dot H I'm going
to do the same thing for the CPP file
vertex buffer dot CPP vertex buffer CPP
is going to include bed X bar for H
I'm also going to right-click on a
vertex buffer vertex buffer and rename
it to vertex buffer because I did miss
buildup okay cool
now if I go back to my header file
notice type in class vertex buffer I'm
going to have one private member just
for now called unsigned int M renderer
ID now I did say just for now but it
will have that forever what I meant is
we're just gonna add just one member
from now now M renderer ID right let's
talk about this for a little bit so we
know that OpenGL needs some kind of
numeric ID in this case it's an unsigned
integer that actually kind of keeps
track of what it's an ID basically for
every type of object we allocate you
know we're like create in in OpenGL
right so if I create a texture if I
create a shader by creative vertex
buffer an index buffer a vertex array a
frame buffer whatever it gets some kind
of ID and that ID is a unique ID that is
an integer that identifies that specific
Buffalo that specific object that I've
created that's how it works now I am
calling this a renderer ID because other
api's also work on a similar system
right so what I'm really doing here is
just kind of keeping it fairly generic
even though this is an OpenGL series so
I am tying things very closely to OpenGL
you know instead of just coming kind of
calling this OpenGL idea or just ID or
like I don't know what I called it
before buffer or whatever renderer ID is
just the actual internal renderer ID so
if you're using OpenGL as your renderer
this is the numeric ID that is actually
relevant to OpenGL because we may have a
high level kind of engine side ID that
we also use file projects like that all
right so yeah just just trying to
explain what I'm doing here because I'm
not trying to kind of um this series is
going to be kind of tough for me to do
it ok now we're breaking like the fourth
wall here but anyway this there is gonna
be kind of tough for me to do because
I'm trying to teach you guys OpenGL but
also I'm trying to mix it in with how
you'll likely be using OpenGL and those
are two different things because if you
look at any OpenGL tutorial they just
show you how OpenGL works and that's
great
but that doesn't tell you about how to
use it in a game or how to use it in an
engine or how to use it in the real
world I'm kind of trying to mix the two
I hope this makes sense this is
obviously a minor case but as the series
goes on if you have any thoughts just
leave a comment below I am here I'm
human I'm here to help you I want to
improve this series as much as you
probably want to see it improved just
leave your thoughts in the comments
below anyway let's just get back to this
a so we have a render ID I'm going to
make a cobbler constructor here I'm
going to take in Constanta data and then
and also an unsigned int size okay we're
going to have a destructor here and
we're just gonna have two functions bind
and unbind I like to add these two now
of course in an actual engine you will
have other things like set data maybe
maybe have a lock and unlock mechanism
so that you can actually kind of stream
data to the vertex buffer as you're kind
of rendering because you met well not as
you're rendering but before you render
the next time you might want to modify
the vertex buffer and so you might kind
of lock it modify it unlock it and do
all that kind of stuff there's a bunch
of stuff you could do here we're gonna
keep it simple for now all we need to
run our current program is find an
unbind as this series goes on and we
start to kind of dive into more
complicated topics and we start to
require those features we're going to
just extend these classes
okay so bind and unbind it looks pretty
good and we have a constructor and a
destructor everything looks pretty good
to me so now let's go back to our CPP
file I'm actually going to go back to my
header file and because I'm using visual
assist I can just right click on the
class name go to quick actions and
create method implementations and it
will ask me which ones I want then I can
hit OK now visual studio also does this
if you kind of hover your mouse over
this and I don't know press the little
arrow you can also generate stuff
generating implementations for your
methods as well okay cool
so what are we doing here if we go back
to that application code all we really
need is if I copy these three lines I'm
gonna put them back over here alright
we're going to include our renderer
because we need that for these shell
call macros and then instead of buffer
it's going to be our end or ID and then
instead of positions it's going to be
data and instead of this thing
going to be sighs and that's really all
we need now I'm going to copy this bind
buffer and put it into bind and unbind
except with unbind I'm going to make it
zero okay pretty simple pretty
straightforward
one more thing we're gonna add here is
of course the deleting of this vertex
buffer so I'm just going to write she'll
call Jill delete the buffers when I
delete one buffer and it's going to be
our end or our ID okay that's it that is
our entire vertex buffer class how
simple is that
now let's repeat the same thing for an
index buffer now because these classes
are so similar I'm actually just going
to open this containing folder and I'm
going to literally copy and paste this
vertex buffer these both of these files
the header file and the CPP file and
it's renamed to index buffer because
that's how similar they are okay back in
visual studio hit this little button
here to refresh this you can see we have
two new files select both of them right
click include in project and then let's
start
refactoring them sir this is an index
buffer now render ID stays there beyond
the other thing we need is an actual
count because we need to know how many
indices this actually has going to
replace this with index buffer of course
instead of vertex buffer conformed
account for data now for now we're going
to support 32-bit indices I don't know
if it's even worth adding 16-bit
entities at this point especially in
this series just know that obviously you
can have different integer types
different integer sizes for your index
buffer you can have 16-bit integers so
like shorts unsigned shorts you can have
32-bit as well welcome to use 32-bit I
don't think there's a reason for us to
support both really of course
theoretically there are performance
benefits to using 16-bit integers if you
don't if you're if you feel 3d model
that you're drawing isn't like that
complex doesn't have that many triangles
that it requires more than 65,000 65535
different not six five five three six
different indices but we keep it simple
unsigned int so Const unsigned int data
now because we've supplied it unsigned
int and not a void there's no point for
us really taking a bite size what we
instead want is the count so how many
indices are we supplied now I like to
distinguish these two by using
sighs and count when I write sighs when
I create a variable called size that is
almost always in bytes if for some
reason it's not they'll probably I'll
definitely leave a comment or something
but like in the actual source code but
size means bites count means element
account so in other words if I have if
I'm drawing the square and I know that
six indices right six indices that means
if I write the number six that's the
count right I don't write six times four
which is 24 that would be this size 24
is a size six is the count okay and
that's all we need here let's go back to
this implementation file now I'm going
to just hit ctrl H over here to bring up
this Find and Replace thing and won't
replace vertex buffer with index buffer
and then hit old age to replace all in
this file current make sure it's in
current document obviously and there we
go
so now I'll get rid of this and replace
it with what I had there which visual
assist can help me out with again and
then finally instead of size and data
here I'm going to write instead of size
primaries when we count times size of
unsigned int now there may be some
danger here because I'm obviously
assuming that the size of an unsigned
int is the same as G eluent because I
specifically know using that platform
differences I've never seen and I'm
signed in not before by it's to be
honest
yeah like never you might be on a
platform where it's not keep that in
mind I I don't really like using the
OpenGL one so I'm still gonna write
unsigned int here but just keep that in
mind you may want to even be complex
really cautious at runtime and
potentially check to see if the size of
an unsigned int is actually equal to the
size of a GL you int make sure you use
the type right not the actual like
during right chill unsigned in because
that's that's not a time make sure you
write glu int but you you may want to be
like really cautious with that but um
anyway I'm just going to use on sign did
the other thing we need to replace is a
write buffer becomes element array
buffer that's really it I mean if I go
down here I'm just going to write bind
buffer here to be LMS write buffer and
that's it
the other thing we obviously need to do
is still discount somehow
I'm going to write an initialize a list
here that just sets count to count like
that up here and then finally a get up
and in line unsigned int get count Const
return M account I'm actually also going
to my mark bind and unbind as Const
because they don't actually modify
anything and we'll probably want to call
them on Const objects in the future
same for the vertex buffer as well so
vertex buffer bind and unbind are
becoming Const okay there we go so
that's it that's really all there is to
extracting those two let's go ahead and
replace the code that we've got in the
application will see the CPP file with
this new kind of these new classes that
we've created sorry back an application
built CPP I'm going to include both of
them at the top here so include vertex
buffer and include index buffer and then
I'm going to scroll down here and then
when we actually create this vertex
buffer I'm going to leave all this code
and write a vertex buffer actually I'm
not gonna delete all of it because I'll
need to copy parts of it I'll try a
vertex buffer VB we're going to write
this as the size and then positions as
the data so positions and then that size
there we go beautiful now we actually
bind it automatically here if we look at
vertex buffer in the code we actually
wrote we never unbind it we just leave
it bound so theoretically we don't need
to call B B dot bind after we do this
because it or it will already be bound
but obviously if we have multiple like
if we create a few like this we'll have
to rebind the ones that we want to use
but that'll be handled by the vertex
array anyway since the vertex array is
associated with a vertex buffer and when
we start up track abstracting the vertex
array we will see how that works okay
so back here we're gonna do the same
thing for index buffer so index buff up
IB indices is the actual buffer and then
instead of six times size of unsigned
end we just need to write six because we
know we're supplying unsigned
okay beautiful get rid of all that as
well the other thing we leave here is
the actual vertex array stuff right the
vertex kind of buffer layout stuff but
other than that that's really all we
need now finally instead of binding this
here we just write I bead or bind and
then draw elements is something that you
could theoretically put into your index
buffer the thing is like the way that
this usually works is that you will like
if you have a complex 3d model like a
spaceship right you will probably have a
vertex buffer that just contains every
single vertex of that spaceship and that
might be like fairly big but then you
may have several index buffers that
draws parts of that ship because the
wings will probably be a different
material than the actual glass cockpit
right so the the cockpit glass when you
draw the cockpit windows they'll
probably be like a glass material
whereas the wings might be a metal
material so you'll have to split them up
into two different drawer holes and the
way that you'll usually do that is
you'll have an index buffer that just
draws the wings and an index buffer the
just draws the actual glass like cockpit
glass and all that stuff and we'll
definitely talk more about that when we
start loading 3d models and start
rendering stuff for reals but that's
just a basic example and so because of
that you still have the one vertex
buffer and then you have several index
buffers that are just indexed into that
vertex buffer and so what you could do
is you could tie your draw your draw
elements or actual draw all to your
index buffer because theoretically the
index buffer is kind of a thing that's
like a camera I'm going to draw the like
this many indices starting at this
offset and all that kind of stuff we're
not actually going to do that because
we're gonna let the renderer take care
of the actual draw call so when we
expand our renderer class to actually
take in you know but like I want to draw
something I'm supplying you with the
vertex but for an index but for a
material all that stuff it will just
look at the index buffer and ask it what
the count is and then issue the draw
whole itself so that's just like if
you're concerned about why I'm not
putting draw elements into the index
buffer and you've seen that before
that's why
just gonna let the renderer class take
care of that okay cool so if we hit up
five just now to verify that our card
actually still works because that's
important you can see does and
everything's great now quick quick
little tip here I'm not really a tip of
thought if we close this you can see our
application doesn't terminate and if we
hit pause over here to just pause the
debugger and see what's up you can see
some GL clear error let's look at the
course tab and see what's going on here
so we're calling Geo clear error looks
like it's an infinite loop and is coming
from index buffer destructor which is
coming from main that's because it's
trying to clean up all of our stack
allocated objects in other words this
index buffer is trying to clean that up
now the thing with this is that you can
see that this is a stack allocated
object so it's destructor is called when
the scope exits which is of course at
the end of this main function
however we called lfw terminate which
destroys our OpenGL context before that
so what's actually happening is we now
no longer have an open get a valid
OpenGL context and GL check error
believe it or not will return an OpenGL
error if there is no context this is one
of the reasons why I think I've been
jealous just comedy but yes the check
error function will return an error if
there's no valid OpenGL context and
since OpenGL itself tells you how you
should be running this in a loop every
time you call it it'll return an error
so it's an infinite loop so one thing
you could do to fix this is of course
heap allocate your actual vertex array
which you sorry your vertex buffer and
your index buffer and then delete it
before you jealous of each other which
is what you probably should do anyway
it's very rare to see them actually be
stack allocated well yeah it's probably
rare to see them be stack allocated
anyway so what we can do here is
actually well technically speaking we
could just make these pointers and
allocate them using new and then delete
them explicitly like over here right so
before we gel at I'll be terminate and
that would fix our problem however this
is kind of a unique case because we're
actually making vertex buffers in the
main function
stop which is very rare another thing we
could do obviously just pray and you
start sorry here's one way to fix it I'm
going to make a skirt around these
dispositions thing here and have it
whoops just minimize everything I'm
gonna create a strip around like just
before this positions thing and then
have it end like over here like that
okay so it's a bit hard to say but if i
zoom out maybe it'll be easier to see
even though the text is really tiny you
can see I've made a scope of here and
it's kind of over here alright so
theoretically that should contain
everything so if I just hit f5 turn on
my code now hopefully we haven't corny
variables outside I get good at compiles
so everything's running now and then if
I hit close you can see the application
actually terminates so I'll just look
quick little thing I wanted to throw in
just to fix it back because that was a
bit annoying when we closed it and it
didn't actually terminate so we had to
terminate it through visual studio which
is annoying but anyway that's it
so we've abstracted the vertex buffer
and the index buffer class I think this
episode was fairly casual probably talks
pretty quickly but that's because this
stuff is really straightforward and I
hope you understood everything that I
did there were some random thoughts here
as well let me know what you thought of
the video by just dropping a like if you
liked it and leaving a comment and just
being like hey man this was like
terrible you should stop this whole
usually the Tanglers probably won't
matter anyway next time we're going to
abstract the shader class I'll actually
no we're gonna do the vertex for a class
first and the shader class and then
probably the renderer you guys like
these videos of mine and you want to
support what I do here on YouTube with
C++ series and OpenGL series in the soon
to come game engine series which is
actually coming very soon by the way the
then you can head on over to patreon
home for search the churner and
contribute to helping support this
series and everything that I do and
you'll get some cool rewards we're about
to have the weekly partner sorry the
monthly partner hang out I think this
week actually where we basically just
hang out and we talk like all other
partner level tier patreon patrons thing
we hang out and we just talk about stuff
for like an hour and actually
fun and there's some other cool rewards
such as access to this source code kind
of episode by episode yeah thank you
huge thank you again to all the patrons
because this series would not be here
without them and I will see you next
time goodbye
[Music]